so let's take a quick moment and talk
about something else that's very
important to game development what
format your images are in now typically
on the internet when you find photos or
pictures of cats just floating around on
random web pages it's actually in a JPEG
format jpg was developed some time ago
by a joint efforts group from some of
the industry's largest contributors now
when I say a while ago actually mean
back in you know the early days of the
internet back when Al Gore still rode
the moon worm through the plains of
ended off another type of image format
that you can use on the internet today
is actually one called PNG now where
JPEG gives you better size comparison
PNG lacks in that department however PNG
does give you one important feature
transparency jpg itself gives you better
compression formats but doesn't allow
you to use transparent pixels in your
scene which means the general rule of
thumb is if you have an image on the
internet that doesn't require it to be
transparent you should probably be using
JPEG if it requires alpha you need to be
using PNG now the cool thing about the
Internet is that it's always moving
forward and new technologies are being
developed every day to make the
experience for end-users better
besides jpg and PNG there's a new image
format coming down the pipe called web P
web P offers an interesting ground first
off it has compression ratios similar if
not better in some cases than JPEG but
also allows you to have alpha
transparency supported by PNG therefore
we have with this new image format the
ability to get good compression and
alpha transparency where we need it
don't you love the Internet